[Musique]
hier en plein après midi alors que
personne ne s'y attendait a été annoncée
la déchirante disparition d'une fierté
nationale un champion de rugby aimé de
tous qui nous quitte à l'âge de 48 ans
c'est dans le parc de saint cloud près
de paris que le champion a été aperçue
pour la dernière fois hier aux alentours
de 15 heures par plusieurs passants
d'après les premières informations
provenant de la police il serait monté
sur un bâtiment désaffecté au de 20
mètres située au bord de l'autoroute a13
c'est de là qu'il se serait jeté dans le
vide
christophe dominici un homme qui depuis
des années à partager à plusieurs
reprises ses douleurs et épisodes
dépressifs sévères pour m'a permis de
trouver leur place dans la société de me
reconstruire de m cette colère cette
haine en carrière que j'avais au service
d'un collectif
[Musique]
il fera la rencontre de bernard laporte
en 1993 lorsqu'il entre au rc toulon est
un art sera d'ailleurs l'entraîneur qui
lui offrira sa première titularisation
lors d'un match de top 14 mais ils
diront ensemble bien plus qu'une
relation joueur entraîneur bernard
laporte deviendra pour lui un véritable
ami puisque christophe deviendra même le
parrain de sa fille
christophe dominici un champion à la
carrière magistral au cours de laquelle
il remportera deux tournois des six
nations et décrochera cinq titres de
champion de france bernard laporte est
avec nous ce soir
pour lui rendre hommage merci bernard
d'être là leur bernard tu es mon pote
voilà j'ai pensé beaucoup à toi hier
aujourd'hui aussi je sais que tu as été
extrêmement touché bien sûr par la
disparition de christophe dominici
c'était ton ami intime tt son
sélectionneur en équipe de france
comment tu as appris la nouvelle hier je
vais d'abord merci de lui rendre hommage
je crois qu'il omet de le mettre mais
j'adore il ce joueur c'était un génie
parce que ici je suis venu j'ai refusé
tout l'été les suisses venus parce que
dans cette émission de sport et que ça
m'a touché je me suis dit au quotidien
merci bernard et de lui je crois qu'une
fois c'était certainement devoir se
passer j'avais appris de jeu me garer
l'appareil et c'était un ami à nous qui
me dit je suis son fils est jeté je sais
pas si c'est jeter si ces textes
intériste et khalil en quelques longs il
faut pas aller plus vite que ça que
l'anc est mais c'est vrai que c'est
difficile inquiet parce que parce que
c'était tout ce que j'aime c'est telara
j'ai juste envie de finir on sait que tu
la mets dans une équipe ça vivait
toujours mais il avait un réel besoin
des autres ça c'est clair mais nous
avions énormément besoin de lui et je
voulais anti que les histoires j'écris
un livre jour suivi parce que ces 24
heures sur 24 savent y avait quoi que tu
permets que tu viens à lire est toujours
les bonnes solutions il était assez
evans premier coup il était généreux et
c'est pour ça que j'ai du mal à
comprendre ce que cette fin de vie vous
vous en doutiez qu'il était vraiment mal
ou pas du tout non il ya eu un épisode
de cet été ou avec des ddd et personne
et devais reprendre un club le club de
béziers mais ça s'est passé je sais
qu'il en était malheureux parce qu'il
avait envie de revenir là le rubis la
même nous ont aidé et il avait envie de
voile à deux ris qu'il a vécu pendant
vingt ans avec nous mais je ne sentais
pas je l'avais eue la semaine dernier je
ne sais pas
pas mal c'est pas c'est pas vrai on
parlait beaucoup il adoré cette équipe
là ils jouent aujourd'hui parce que
d'abord il a joué dans les intérieurs
qui y sont et cetera ils disaient nous
régale et c'est super pour le rugby non
c'est sam an à 2,5 milieu de m'imaginer
ce qui s'est passé vous l'aviez vu
dernièrement j'ai vu la semaine dernière
mercredi ouvre les vannes partir à
l'école et voilà en parler supplice
matteo joueur il parlait de vous vous
aimez mais joseph il met tout le monde
christophe système semry gentil ce que
ce matin vous avez été par les joueurs
oui j'ai pas le jour parce que j'ai pas
parlé parce que c'est mon ami j'ai
choisi parce que c'est l'institution qui
doit parler c'est la fédération
française de rugby je suis le président
il ya 67 sélections
c'est ce que j'ai dit à tous ces jeunes
et j'ai dit je vous souhaite qu'une
chose c'est dans sa carrière et être
comme il est et il donnait toujours
verte et trois coupes du monde et c'est
une fois champion de france
ken écartement des six nations pc c'est
l'un des plus gros palmarès
donc oui j'ai dit aux joueurs il faut
qu'on ait une pensée pour lui tout
simplement les les joueurs se sont levés
l'ont applaudi et ça marche et ça m'a
fait du bien il ya un match samedi soir
y aura il y aura un no man's voyez il y
aura un hommage samedi soir bien sûr il
rend l'image aussi ou des joueurs de
safran s'est donc dit dans dix jours le
dimanche soir où tous les joueurs
viennent du canada
j'ai vu que tout le monde répondait sur
la table tout le monde veut venir parce
que parce que tout le monde et tu vois
moi tout simplement
alors regardez on a des images
[Applaudissements]
sk policiers partis qui s'en donnent ici
en prévenant de christophe
et c'est un génie et c'est
extraordinaire on sent clairement tes
jouets de la paroisse n'est gagné un
coup de pied dans la porte comme aux
antilles un rebond favorable christophe
résolution qui surgit dans cet effet
bernard vous admiriez on l'a c'est vous
qui commentent ils en plus en voix vous
êtes comme un fou la ccc votre joueur
c'est votre ami qui fait un exploit
oui plus j'avais été le chercher à
toulouse avait deux ans qui était à
paris il fait la coupe du monde mais
jugé la chasse de commenter la coupe du
monde effectivement mais voilà j'étais
tellement ravie d'avoir programmé tracée
pour lui bien sûr
alors vous voulez me énormément il vous
le rendra bien puisque on se souvient
qui vous avait encensé pour avoir obtenu
l'organisation de la coupe du monde 2023
en france regardez nous ce soir notre
consultant rugby proche du grand patron
marc laporte christophe dominici bonsoir
à vous bonsoir je crois que bien dans la
forme mobile monstrueux pendant cette
quinzaine
ce mec me surprendre de plus en plus et
si des joueurs sur le terrain
le même état d'esprit que lui cet esprit
de compétition et cette soif de gagner
je crois qu'on en gagnera beaucoup plus
de matchs honnêtement forcément il a
fallu jouer des coudes mais il est
arrivé et quelle classe quand le bernard
cette capacité à pouvoir fédérer a
derrière lui
donc bien sûr ça donne envie de le
suivre ça c'est sûr si c'est lui
bernard est ce que ce que vous auriez eu
envie de lui dire une dernière chose à
ce qu'il est parti sous denman vous vous
y attendiez pas du tout c'est ça que tu
as encore plus douloureux oui je pouvais
pas lui parler du génial pourquoi c'est
pas du tout pourquoi ils n'ont pas tout
imaginer plein de choses mais est elle
même non moi je ne sais pas je serai
peut-être à chaud et vous savez chacun à
son jardin secret c'est pas tous les
jours on le saura voilà mais bon il est
plus là ce qui est important c'est
d'aider ceux qui sont là bas son épouse
cette fille 91 ans séparent accueillir
d'orange annoncent de fortes à consommer
avec eux parce que leur mère
au téléphone je suis son père jean mais
on sera présents puis je parle au nom de
tous ceux qui ont joué avec lui j'ai pas
tout seul beaucoup de joueurs étrangers
qui à moi des bons partout tu verras
gérer mort son papa de même il est monté
il est à paris puis voilà non moi je
sais bien passé pour lui mais il reste
dix années à vivre pour beaucoup de gens
autour
quand vous avez son papa au téléphone et
que son fils a suicide à 48 ans est
tellement vous trouvez propre
je lui ai dit ça mais sûre il pleure il
avait du mal à parler et ça me fait
plaisir des chocs que tu m'appelles g
mais janot soit plus pleurer un certain
moment il faut déplorer le fret en
costaud sur le bel20 jeu trois mois tout
le monde est là et je te prouver ne vont
pas très bien
samedi soir donc y aura un hommage bien
entendu au stade de france
et je vous assure succédé depuis hier
tout le monde est très ému par ce drame
donc c'est que le quinze de france en ce
moment là se préparait vous êtes allé ce
matin comme de la vie dit elle
sélectionneur fabien galthié qui
connaissait parfaitement aussi
christophe dans la vie comme sur le
terrain qui avait l'air très très très
ému l'ambiance ce matin
elle est au plus bas c'est difficile
pour familles et messieurs pour les deux
sélectionneurs raphaël fabien william
servat que bendtner ils ont joué avec
lui la famille d'agnès
c'est moi qui leur ai appris la nouvelle
hier c'est vrai j'ai senti que j'étais
touché parce que c'est tellement normal
je veux dire ça ça nous est tous arrivé
c'est frais c'est pas exceptionnel ça
arrive à tout le monde d enquête et
yvonne quatre touches de l'école s'est
soudain comme ça c'est oui cassé sous
des comme ça c'est un fait encore plus
mal
voilà donc c'est pour ça que tu rends
hommage samedi soir c'est une lichette
une évidence regardez famille gatti il a
porté le maillot bleu avec tellement
d'énergie tellement de passion et
christophe c'est c'est surtout notre ami
nous pensons très fort à sa famille ses
proches et bien sûr
les clubs où il a joué une sur
solliès-pont toulon le stade français
bien sûr tous ses amis tous les
supporters et et ça me dit bien sûr nous
allons tâcher de lui rendre hommage
alors on va attendre les conclusions de
l'enquêté bien entendu bernard est ce
que le monde du sport à ce que le monde
du rugby c'est un monde difficile
alors quand tu joues comme ça non je
crois pas que ce monde difficile c'est
pour ça que je veux tout savoir pourquoi
d'évidence on skie sauf il était comme
tout le monde ils avaient où il avait
débarqué comme tout le monde mais pas à
ce que ça qu'on doit faire et que ça
veut dire quelqu'un mourait de ce que je
suis c'est à dire d'être quelqu'un qui
les connaît tous le temps tout en tout
le temps tout le temps tout le temps
dans un groupe fait à chaque fois que je
sélectionnais dix neuf ans et des fois
je n'y avais mal par ce panel et demi je
n'ai pas pris ma vous voulez j'ai visité
aujourd'hui de 7 et moins de monde que
certains noms je te prends pas mais il
me manquait tellement pas comme un
joueur mais marque quand on jouait pas
c'est là qu'il était sur le terrain on
le voit qu'ils l'étaient pas mais en
dehors ils étaient les mots sont
toujours à les connaître une pente très
raide et son nom et je me rappelle les
toulousains puis je voudrais français
toulousaine clermontois tout le monde
comme son volet 1 sélection mais tout le
monde est toujours autour de lui on
attend de sa connerie
qu'est ce qu'il allait faire voilà
c'était un meneur comme on est un
bouquin mondial du terme voilà quelqu'un
qui avait la rage et la joie de vivre et
manassé certainement des fragilités
aussi qu'est-ce que vous rien retiendrez
lui la première image qui vous vient ce
que je retiens de lui c'est son sourire
et son regard malin son regard qui
visait captation je peux faire une
connerie à tout moment c'était ça qui
sauf sur le terrain des pareilles se
pressent sur têt c'était pareil
attention quand j'ai le ballon je suis
jamais bonjour euh c'était comme ça ils
étaient sur le terrain comme unité dans
la vie ou dans la vie comme l'était
soutien à ce regard bernard je voudrais
vous remercier
non non merci à vous surtout je lis je
suis venu parce qu' il fallait parler à
l'aller au journal de tf1 dans le
journal truc ses fils il est vrai pas
pour faire les choses puis ce matin je
me suis décalé mais aussi à développer
tient il à bord estime que j'ai pour toi
tu le sais puis
je me suis dit sa démission du sport
voilà ça fait ce film est de 4 heures
moment il faut lui rendre hommage
je vous dis on a aussi des pmp on n'est
pas une émission en une émission de
divertissement
on parle de tout forcément ça on a parlé
d'écologie on a parlé au journalisme
avec harry roselmack et on voulait
absolument nous aussi rendre hommage à
ce grand joueur parce que les valeurs du
rugby est une somme moins incroyable
mois voilà je suis fan de rugby
j'étais un des fans deux joueurs tous
absolument lui rendre hommage il ya
plein de gens sur les réseaux sociaux
qui m'ont dit thierry j'espère tu va
rendre hommage à christophe dominici et
bernard je voudrais vraiment te
remercier entraînement est venu nous
voir et tu nous a rendu un hommage est
tu l'a rendu un hommage
vraiment c'est incroyable ce soir